joining me here once again at a Super
Bowl two years in a row now it's kind of
like a tradition unlike any other it's
kind of like the Masters a little bit
from the Carolina Panthers courtesy of
our friends at Old Spice right here on
the Rich Eisen show one of the best
running backs in the business Christian
McCaffrey good to see you sir good to
see you thanks for having me you bet
how's life it's good this well yeah well
calm right before you looked back the
trainings right it's going well are you
the last count on a panther standing is
that right it's been a weird year you
know and it's always a bummer it's the
sad reality of the league guys come and
go but right you know it does feel like
I've lost a few of my brothers along the
way but I'm happy for everyone moving on
you know you know I'm sure they'll be
good did you see Keeley's decision
coming or you didn't know I didn't you
know but you know I didn't I didn't but
I think at the end of the day what I'm
so excited for him for it
he went out on his own terms which is
more than most people can say I made a
decision that was best for himself and I
was honored I got to play with him for
three years you know obviously selfishly
I wish I could have played it in my
whole career sure but but I mean what
what a standout human being standout
athlete one of the best to ever do and
the way he did it you know I was pretty
cool that I was able to witness that
every day yeah and I thought it was
really neat that the Panthers put the
basically raw video of his statement up
like it wasn't edited it was him out
there getting emotional yep you know and
doing his thing I I love that guy I got
a chance to meet him a couple of times
and I know exactly how you feel about
him
yeah and no one Luka me he probably said
hey look I'll announce it you just film
me and we'll post it and and and then he
probably went hunting somewhere and you
know left and that's that's just who he
is so that's that's kind of just a good
testament of the kind of guy he is
simple guy Roy doesn't need a whole lot
but plays and trains and practiced a
hundred percent all the time Christian
McCaffrey here on the Rich Eisen show
and now Matt rule is your coach your
head coach and he just jumped through
the television screen at his press
conference I mean that was something
what your conversations been like with
him so far oh you know I mean they're so
busy
trying to figure out you know the staff
and I try not to bug them too much but
you have connected with yeah but have
connected yep talked to him a few times
now and it's exciting because you can
tell that that he's fired up and and
obviously anyone would be but there's a
there's a really good energy in the
building and I think I'm excited for our
team you know we had a lot of great
young guys who are hungry we got a lot
of good mix between you know young guys
and veteran leadership so I think we got
the right guys for him to step into and
we're excited to work for him
who's handing you the ball next year do
you think I have no idea I wish I had
those answers now right you know I I
don't know I I just you know try to stay
in my lane and and you know the guys
that I know are gonna be with us try to
take them along and you know learn from
everybody you know we got so many guys
on the team who are leaders now you know
guys like DJ Moore was going in his
third year who you know it's gonna step
up as a leader guys like Curtis Samuel
who's gonna step into a leadership
position and you know for me it's it's
it's taken that and and and working with
everybody and you know doing whatever he
can to win game so cam have you are you
in connection with him yep had dinner
with him last night yeah so what did he
order what did he what did he order what
did you have what did he order this is
true story okay we're at prime 112 loved
it very good restaurant night I've never
been before the great restaurant in
fancy it was a who's who you know
everybody's there I've been twice
already this way yeah so this is no this
is no joke you know people are ordering
you know wine and and you know nice
steaks and I he asked the the the waiter
he said can I do you guys have a vegan
grilled cheese and we're all like that
he just ordered a grilled cheese grown
man ordering a grilled cheese at a
steakhouse yeah and he got his grilled
cheese vegan grilled cheese and he
enjoyed it and we we had a great dinner
a big what is what is a vegan I don't
know I I don't know I I don't have any
answers past that but
that's uh that's who he is he's the best
guy in the world he's somebody that
there's no one in the world like him and
heck of a leader heck of a teammate you
know he's a guy who as a player you know
watching him in practice watching him in
the games there's not a lot of
quarterbacks who you know die over piles
fight for every yard throw out blocks
the way he does and completely
sacrifices his body for the team and
unfortunately he's dealt with some
injuries in you know the last couple
years but you know it's a lot of fun
playing with him you know I'm lucky to
have him as a teammate I gotta be honest
with you Christian you know asking you
what did he order last night is a weird
question but I feel like I've been
rewarded by yeah that was a heck of a
question you know I mean I didn't know
how is gonna be respond but I'm very
proud of myself right now yeah yeah
Christian McCaffrey here on the Rich
Eisen show oh yeah thank you that's an
applause line I appreciate better so
speaking of staying in your lane your
lane was not supposed to be between the
tackles that's a professional football
player right what do you think you have
proven so far Christian I don't know you
know III I used to be a little bitter
about you know what people would say
about me coming out of college and if I
could play or not and I've kind of kind
of pushed that to the side and
new you know new attitude about
everything and I realized that everybody
in the league has had somebody doubt him
at some point so I try to you know focus
on myself and good or bad stay pretty
poised and and go from there well I
remember when you were coming out and my
buddy on the air and my buddy in life
marshall faulk would scoff at the notion
that you Christian McCaffrey would not
be able to run between the tackles that
you would be more of a elite sort of
weapon in the NFL that can come in every
now and then and gain the edge and run
he was basically like that's nonsense
and he said this week that you are quote
unquote a better version of him he's a
better version of me is what he said
what did did you hear him say yeah yeah
I mean that's a huge honor huge honor
it's a guy watched I've seen every clip
of his obviously somebody who was in a
thousand thousand category as well and
and so for me hearing that from a guy
like that is a big honor I don't you
know he did one thing I that that I
respect and I heard this you know from a
lot of different players in the league
is it's really good when you have one or
two really good years but but the greats
do it over their entire career and when
you talk about Marshall Faulk you know I
got a lot of work to do as far as I know
I'm going into year four that's an
unbelievable honor that he even
mentioned that but I'm excited to try to
try to continue to do it and do it
throughout my entire career that he did
it he it it took him six years to do it
Roger Craig did it now you're the only
other thousand thousand person in in the
NFL in NFL history I do want to ask you
about this because I thought this was
really neat did you give a couple
tickets to the Super Bowl to a Marine
did you do that yeah yeah so I you know
I work a lot with the military and every
year we do it where I give away tickets
and and I've last few years I've done it
with veterans and this is actually the
first year we gave away tickets to
active duty military members so sergeant
major Leyva and his brother Jorge was
really cool I'm gonna get to meet him
later but anytime I'm able to do stuff
with the military I jump right to it I
have a huge heart for you know our
veterans and our active
duty military members so that'll be a
fun little deal that I'm excited for I'm
from that's that's so awesome so okay so
you're now waiting to see what Matt
rules playbook is clearly because we're
you're in that period where you're not
allowed to just dive in is that the case
right now you already got on that yeah
I've taught I've talked to Coach rule
I've talked to coach Brady and we're not
at the playbook stuff yet I'm itching to
get it but um you know I think that'll
be in future talks yeah coach Brady
we've got Joe burrow coming on later on
and on what he was part of with burrow
this year at LSU is just absolutely
insane
it was it was impressive to watch so did
you see is that we can assumes some of
the same concepts that's coming your way
I think I think the coolest thing to
watch is you know there's not one you
know this is our scheme it's a constant
change of what they're doing based on
what the defense is doing based on who
they have on the field and it's it's a
it's a consistent effort I guess to put
the ball in your best guy's hands and
allow them to do what they do okay
solo you brought this bag with you let
me take a look in here just part of the
old spice absolutely going on yeah they
just dropped their ultra smooth line and
okay it's now being sold at Walgreens
they have it in a deodorant they have it
in a body wall okay and it's about
smelling fresh man I mean you look great
and dress well but you got a smell fresh
- so are you talking about me
specifically or people in general are
you specific Thank You Christian I
appreciate that yeah just you cuz you
brought there were two in the bag -
ultra smooth in the bag you brought a
third is that a sign for me or did you
bring from my third for a crew member
these guys work hard I'm sure there's
okay whitey days okay so and they're
gonna need it well we have a lot of
ultra smooth individuals on the
Richardson shows staff that's right um
but the name of the show is me yeah and
there is an iron-rich and Eisen so I
might have all three you sure yeah there
is an I in anti and purse Parente as
well I just noticed that I just noticed
that sorry you wrote that down like you
know what take it yeah just take it
spice needs to hire you do you think so
yeah
that was impressive thank you very much
Christian I appreciate that well they're
all standing by here they're all talking
with one another yeah your people will
speak to my people by the end of this
day I think I'm gonna turn to my rider
left at some point and have Greg Olson
looking at me in a booth what do you
think guys ready to that's another guy
mean you talk about Luke Kuechly and and
you talk about guys like Greg Olson and
I mean he was you know I mean the the
Panthers made jokes about you know he's
my you know father cuz blond hair blue
eyes older guy and you know I'm smaller
than him so any picture we took together
was like you guys look like father-son
but but he's he's somebody who it's hard
to put into words what he brought to the
table on and off the field and and what
he's done in the community what he's
done for for the city and and sharing
hearing his story with with him his wife
and his in his son TJ who would you know
struggled with heart issues as a young
kid and what he's done with that with
that foundation yeah and and and you
know I love talking about stuff off the
field because it's the stuff that people
don't always know about obviously he's a
heck of a player you know had a thousand
yards receiving three years in a row but
but he's such a great guy and another
guy that you know I'm gonna miss it's
it's sad I'm like how many how many
goodbyes can I say in one month it's
been a lot but you know I'm gonna miss
him a lot in a way it might just be you
know your team like it's your job to get
in there and say this is the locker room
and I know that there's a new coach here
and they might look to you do you think
yeah yeah I mean I think I think the the
interesting part when you struggle for a
couple years in a row I think it's a
clean slate you know there isn't there
is nobody who's exempt of being a leader
I don't you know and in my opinion I
don't care if you're a rookie or you're
a ten year guy I think everyone's at the
same level I think when when you've won
a Super Bowl or you've won Super Bowls
and you're you know your team's 1 in 11
games a year then you have your set
standard leaders but but you know and
when you win five games everybody I mean
we need everybody to be a leader and I
think that's that's we have the right
guys to do that well it's good to have
you here again I I don't know if I'm
gonna be a colleague of Greg Olsen's
just yet I think he still wants to play
some more football which would be great
for everybody but yeah
it's great to have you here thank you
for coming thank you yes is Christian
McCaffrey at CMC underscore 22 on
Twitter and at Christian McCaffrey on
Instagram and you can get new Old Spice
ultra-smooth at Walgreens
nice deep bag is in fact mine to Zags
yours all three of yours actually the
bags good for you guys thank you no I'll
keep the the actual gear right here
thanks for coming on Thank You someone
that's Christian McCaffrey America's
Sweetheart for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app